en 2014 cent cinquante mille personnes
ont participé à une course à obstacles
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une course à
obstacles une course à obstacles
c'est une course on va parcourir un
parcours avec des obstacles s'est
inspiré du parcours du combattant un
exercice militaire s'est inspiré des
accrobranche des parcours aventure et
sainte east ca s'inscrit dans une méta
tendance autour de l'effort personnel et
du dépassement de soi il y a environ
deux ans j'ai déposé dans mon canapé et
je suis tombé sur un site de course à
obstacles embarqué par un copain j'ai
regardé les images et je me suis dit ces
gens là sont des faux j'avais pas tort
mais cette folie tout cet ensemble de
course d'obstacles va bien au delà de la
discipline et je suis pas là pour vous
faire la promotion de mon sport mais je
suis là pour vous parler de la course à
obstacles en tant qu allégorie du
quotidien la course à obstacles
c'est une discipline de notre temps de
notre époque et qui nous aident chaque
jour à nous sentir plus vivant dans la
vie de tous les jours dans notre
quotidien
nous rencontrons des obstacles ceux ci
sont physiques
demain je vais aller aider un copain a
déménagé ou ceux ci sont psychologiques
mentaux cela peut être les choix de
l'éducation pour son enfant
cela peut être également des difficultés
dans son travail des difficultés dans sa
vie personnelle et face à tous ces
obstacles
nous avons besoin de nous dépasser
nous avons besoin de faire face et nous
avons besoin de capacités parfois
physique souvent mon talent et nous
avons besoin de ressources dans une
course à obstacles
nous allons rencontrer volontairement
des obstacles ceux ci sont physiques
comme on peut le voir avec cette épreuve
du filet mais ceux ci peuvent également
être mentaux il va nous falloir de la
ténacité il va falloir vaincre nos peurs
il va falloir nous dépasser quand on
parle de la course à obstacles on parle
souvent d'un sport extrême d'un sport
fait pour ceux qui veulent aller plus
loin à les toucher leurs limites et un
sport donc de vous ce n'est pas
seulement ça nous allons voir que la
course à obstacles et dans la course à
obstacles chacun a ses propres limites
certains événements vont nous pousser à
nous dépasser en nous amusant en ou
déguisant pour le fun sur des petites
distances
d'autres vont arriver à se dépasser
avec des épreuves plus longues plus long
plus dur plus extrêmes
certains vont même avoir besoin d'aller
chercher la performance chercher la
compétition et la première leçon de la
course à obstacles parce qu'elle nous
apprend dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est que les limites que nous avons
sont propres à chaque personne et que
nous avons besoin de définir nos limites
et en allant vers ses propres limites en
les dépassant
que ce soit physiquement ou mentalement
on va se rendre plus fort et on va ainsi
devenir plus vivant
la course à obstacles cela semble un
sport individuel
la vie de tous les jours c'est un sport
individuel on est seul avec les autres
sartre par leur ai parlé même d'en faire
des autres mais sans les autres en est
rien face aux obstacles
on n'est rien certaines courses propose
des obstacles qui sont infranchissables
seul sans aide
sans solidarité personne ne peut nous
aider et au surtout on ne peut pas
passer et on est forcé à l'abandon pour
se dépasser pour aller plus loin dans la
vie comme dans la course à obstacles on
a besoin de s'entraider
on a besoin de faire avec ceux qui
participent avec nous et la grande leçon
souhaite également que lorsque l'on
court lorsque l'on parcourt on ne sait
pas qui va être notre rythme on ne
connaît pas les personnes une personne
que l'on double on va se dire vas jeu
plus rapide qu'elle tant mieux en fait
non je vais avoir besoin d'elle pour
m'aider et cela nous aide également à
vaincre tous les préjugés
on ne choisit pas qui l'on va aider on
ne choisit pas qui va nous aider et on
ne choisit pas qui peut nous aider à
passer cela cette notion de respect
cette notion d'humilité cette notion
d'entr'aide nous aide dans la vie de
tous les jours et qui ont une excellente
leçon pour notre quotidien
au-delà de ça et c'est souvent ce que
l'on retient des courses à obstacles
c'est qu'il faut être quelqu'un de
complet pour finir une course bien
souvent on voit beaucoup de coureurs qui
s'entraînent dans des salles de
musculation qui ont énormément de
muscles qui vont être capables de monter
à la corde en trois secondes mais qui
vont s'écrouler sur la distance à côté
de ça on va voir des gens qui sont
habitués des marathons et qui vont ramer
sur les obstacles face à une course et
oser pestacles on a tous nos points
forts on a tous nos points faibles et
nous avons besoin d'être des gens
complet cela va nous demander non
seulement de la force et de l'endurance
comme on l'imaginé mais également de
l'est de l'agilité pour passer des
obstacles comme des poutres du dynamisme
pour passer des obstacles qui s'appelle
les monkey bar ou encore des capacités
de mémoire puisque certaines courses
vont donner des épreuves de mémoire tout
ça c'est très chouette mais il ne faut
pas oublier les qualités mentales
requise la solidarité l'humilité de
demander de l'aide
le fait d'avoir une analyse à chaud sur
les obstacles
quand on arrive à fond sur un obstacle
on constate toujours à la bonne solution
certains obstacles sont faits pour être
contournées
quand on voit des murs trop haut de
troncs d'arbres les organisateurs eux
mêmes de 10
mais pourquoi vous avez pas pris du
recul et pourquoi vous n'êtes pas de
passer dessous alors que ce n'était pas
interdit pourquoi ne vous n'avez pas
pris quelques secondes pour penser pour
réfléchir pour demander de l'aide
cette qualité là est indispensable si et
nous devons dans la vie de tous les
pour être complet prendre le temps de
réfléchir pour pouvoir aller plus vite
prendre le temps d'être ensemble pour
pouvoir aller plus loin et tout cela
dans le but de se dépasser de prendre
confiance en soi et de la dalle est de
l'avis de l'avant avec envie avec toutes
ces bonnes dimensions là quand la ligne
d'arrivée arrive on se sent
nécessairement plus vivant on a passé
des obstacles on a passé des coudes des
difficultés certes on est couvert de
boue certes on a quelquefois quelques
égratignures mais on est plus vivant
dans la vie tous les jours nous avons
des obstacles nous avons ce besoin
d'obstacles l'obstacle le plus simple
celui que vous allez rencontrer il y à
la sortie de l'istec quand vous allez
sortir de cette salle où possible pour
vous qui êtes chez vous en streaming
vous allez avoir un simple point de vue
a changé lorsque vous voyez des
escaliers
juste après cette conférence passé les
comme si c'était un obstacle en allant
de l'avant et en se disant je peux le
faire
certes ce sera dur certes c'est vrai
vous demander un effort mais vous vous
sentirez plus vivant merci à tous